hi everyone my name is Alvin and welcome
to our second lecture on deep sequence
modeling so in the first I was lecture
Alexander talked about the essentials of
neural networks and feed-forward models
and now we're going to turn our
attention to applying neural networks to
problems which involve sequential
processing of data and why these sorts
of tasks require a different type of
network architecture from what we've
seen so far so before we dive in I like
to start off with a really simple
example suppose we have this picture of
a ball and we want to predict where it
will travel to next without any prior
information about the ball's history any
guess on its next position will be
exactly that just a guess however if in
addition to the current location of the
ball I also gave you a history of its
previous locations now the problem
becomes much easier and I think we can
all agree that we have a pretty clear
sense of where the ball is going to next
so this is a really really simple
sequence modeling problem given this
this image this you know a thought
experiment of a balls travel through
space can we predict where it's going to
go next but in reality the truth is that
sequential data is all around us for
example audio can be split up into a
sequence of sound waves while text can
be split up into a sequence of either
characters or words and beyond these two
Ubiquiti examples there are many more
cases in which sequential processing may
be useful from analysis of medical
signals like EKGs to predicting stock
trends to processing genomic data and
now that we've gone in the sense of what
sequential data looks like I want to
turn our attention to another simple
problem to to motivate motivate the
types of networks that we're going to
use for this task and in this case
suppose we have a language model where
we're trying to Train
neural network to predict the next word
in a phrase or a sentence and suppose we
have this sentence this morning I took
my cat for a walk yes you heard and read
that right this morning I took my cat
for a walk and let's say we're given
these words this morning I took my cat
for a and we want to predict the next
word in the sequence and since this is a
class on deep learning we're going to
try to build a deep neural network like
a feed-forward Network from our first
lecture to do this and one problem that
we're immediately going to run into is
that our feed-forward network can only
take a fixed length vector as its input
and we have to specify this size of this
input right at the start and you can
imagine that this is going to be a
problem for our task in general because
sometimes we'll have a sentence we'll
have seen five words sometimes seven
words sometimes ten words and we want to
be able to predict what comes next so
fundamentally we need a way to handle
variable length input and one way we can
do this is to use this idea of a fixed
window to force our input vector to be a
certain length in this case - and this
means that no matter where we're trying
to make our prediction we just take the
previous two words and try to predict
the next word and we can represent these
two words as a fixed length vector where
we take a larger vector allocate some
space for the first word some space for
the second word and encode the identity
of each word in that vector but this is
problematic because because of the fact
that we're using this fixed window we're
giving ourselves a limited history which
means that we can't effectively model
long term dependencies in our input data
which is important in sentences like
this one where we clearly need
information from much earlier in the
sentence to accurately predict the next
word if we were only looking at the past
two words or the past three words or the
past five words even we wouldn't be able
to make this prediction being the the
word French
so we need a way to integrate
information from across the sentence but
also still represent the input as a
fixed length vector and another way we
could do this is by actually using the
entire sequence but representing it as a
set of counts and this representation is
what's called a bag of words where we
have some vector and each slot in this
vector represents a word and the value
that's in that slot represents the
number of times that that word appears
in this sentence and so we have a fixed
length vector over some vocabulary of
words regardless of the length of the
input sentence but the counts are just
going to be different and we can feed
this into our feed-forward neural
network to generate a prediction about
the next word and you may have already
realized that there's a big problem with
this approach in using counts we've just
completely abolished all sequence
information and so for example these two
sentences with completely opposite
semantic meanings would have the exact
same bag of words representation same
words same counts so obviously this
isn't going to work
another idea could be to simply extend
our first idea of a fixed window
thinking by thinking that by looking at
more words we can get most of the
context we need and so we can represent
our sentence in this way right just a
longer fixed window feed it into our
feed-forward model and make a prediction
and if we were to feed this vector into
a feed-forward neural network each of
these inputs each 0 or 1 in the vector
would have a separate weight connecting
it to the network and so if we
repeatedly were to see the words this
morning at the beginning of the sentence
the neural network would be able to
learn that this morning represents a
time or a setting but if in another
sentence this morning were to now appear
at the end of that sentence the network
is going to have difficulty recognizing
that this morning actually means this
morning because the
that see the end of the vector have
never seen that phrase before and the
parameters from the beginning haven't
been shared across the sequence and so
at a higher level what this means is
that what we learn about the sequence at
one point is not going to transfer
anywhere to anywhere else in the
sequence if we use this representation
and so hopefully by by walking through
this I've motivated that why a
traditional feed-forward neural network
is not really well suited to handle
sequential data and this simple example
further motivates a concrete set of
design criteria that we need to keep in
mind when thinking about building a
neural network for sequence modeling
problems specifically our network needs
to be able to handle variable length
sequences be able to track long term
dependencies in the data maintain
information about the sequence order and
share the parameters it learns across
the entirety of the sequence and today
we're going to talk about using
recurrent neural networks or RN ends as
a general framework for sequential
processing and sequence modeling
problems so let's go through the general
principle behind RN ends and explore how
they're a fundamentally different
architecture from what we saw in the
first lecture so this is a abstraction
of our standard feed-forward neural
network and in this architecture data
propagates in one direction from input
to output and we already motivated why a
network like this can't really handle
sequential data RNs in contrasts are
really well-suited for handling cases
where we have a sequence of inputs
rather than a single input and they're
great for problems like this one in
which a sequence of data is propagated
through the model to give a single
output for example you can imagine
training a model that takes as input a
sequence of words and outputs a
sentiment that's associated with that
phrase or that sentence alternatively
instead of returning a single output
could also train a model where we take
in a sequence of inputs propagate them
through our recurrent neural network
model and then return an output at each
time step in the sequence and an example
of this would be in text or music
generation and you'll get a chance to
explore this type of model later on in
the lab and beyond these two these two
examples there are a whole host of other
recurrent neural network arctor
architectures for sequential processing
and they've been applied to a range of
problems so what fundamentally is a
recurrent neural network as I mentioned
before to reiterate our standard vanilla
feed-forward neural network we're going
from input to output in one direction
and this fundamentally can't maintain
information about sequential data our
Nan's on the other hand are networks
where they have these loops these loops
in them which allow for information to
persist so in this diagram our RNN takes
as input this vector X of T outputs a
value like a prediction Y hat of T but
also makes this computation to update an
internal state which we call H of T and
then passes this information about its
state from this step of the network to
the next and we call these networks with
loops in them recurrent because
information is being passed internally
from one time step to the next so what's
going on under the hood how is
information being passed our nuns use a
simple recurrence relation in order to
process sequential data specifically
they maintain this internal state H of T
and at each time step we apply a
function parametrized by a set of
weights W to update this state based on
both the previous state H of T minus 1
and the current input X of T and the
important thing to know here is that the
same function and the same set of
parameters are used at every time step
and this addresses that important design
criteria from earlier of why it's useful
to share parameters in the context of
sequence modeling to be more specific
the RNN computation includes both a
state update as well as the output so
given our input vector we apply some
function to update the hidden state and
as we saw in the first lecture this
function is a standard neural net
operation that consists of
multiplication by a weight matrix and
applying a non linearity but in this
case since we both have the input vector
X of T as well as the previous state H
of T minus 1 as inputs to our function
we have two weight matrices and we can
then apply our non-linearity to the sum
of these two terms
finally we generate an output at a given
time step which is a transformed version
of our internal state the foes from a
multiplication by a separate weight
matrix so so far we've seen our n ends
as depicted as having these loops that
feedback back in on themselves another
way of thinking about the RNN can be in
terms of unrolling this loop across time
and if we do this we can think of the
RNN as multiple copies of the same
network where each copy is passing a
message onto its descendant and
continuing this this scheme throughout
time you can easily see that our n ends
have this chain like structure which
rely really highlights how and why
they're so well suited for processing
sequential data so in this
representation we can we can make our
weight matrices explicit beginning with
the weights that transform the inputs to
the hidden state transform the previous
hidden se to the next hidden safe and
finally transform the hidden sate to the
output and it's important once again to
note that we are using the same weight
matrices at every time step and from
these outputs we can
to loss at each time step and this
completes our what is called our forward
pass through the network and finally to
define the total loss we simply sum the
losses from all the individual time
steps and since our total loss consists
of these individual contributions over
time this means that training the
network will also have to involve some
time component okay so in terms of in
terms of actually training our Nets
how can we do this and the algorithm
that's used is an extension of the back
propagation idea that alexander
introduced in the first lecture and it's
called back propagation through time so
to remind you let's let's think back to
how we trained feed-forward models given
our given our inputs we first make a
forward pass through the network going
from input to output and then back
propagate gradients back through the
network taking the derivative of the
loss with respect to each parameter in
the network and then tweaking our
parameters in order to minimize the lost
for our n ends our forward pass through
the network consists of going forward
across time updating the cell state
based on the input and the previous
state
generating an output at each time step
computing a loss I each time set and
then finally summing these individual
losses to get the total loss and what
this means is that instead of back
propagating errors through a single
feed-forward network at a single time
step in our n ends errors are back
propagated at each individual time step
and then across time steps all the way
from where we are currently to the very
beginning of the sequence and this is
the reason why it's called back
propagation through time because as you
can see all the errors are flowing back
in time to the beginning of our data
sequence and so if we take a closer look
at how gradients flow
across this chain of repeating modules
you can see that in between these these
time steps in doing this back
propagation we have this factor whh
which is a matrix and this means that in
each step we have to perform a matrix
multiplication that involves this way
matrix W and furthermore each cell say
update results from a nonlinear
activation and what this means is that
in computing the gradient in an RNN the
derivative of the loss with respect to
our initial state H naught we have to
make many matrix multiplications that
involve the weight matrix as well as
repeated use of the derivative of the
activation function why might this be
problematic well if we consider these
multiplication operations if many of
these values are greater than one what
we can encounter is what's called this
exploding gradient problem where our
gradients become extremely large and we
can't do any optimization and to combat
this one thing that's done is in
practice is called gradient clipping
which basically means you scale back
your gradients when they become too
large and this is a really good
practical option especially when you
have a network that's not too
complicated
with and doesn't have many parameters on
the flip side we can also have the
opposite problem
where if our matrix values are too small
we can encounter what's called the
vanishing gradient problem and it's
really the motivating factor behind the
most widely used RNN architectures and
today we're gonna address three ways in
which we can alleviate the vanishing
gradient problem by changing the
activation function that's used being
clever about how we initialize the
weights in our network and finally how
we can fundamentally change the RNN
architecture to combat this and so
before we go into that let's take a step
back and try to establish some more
intuition as to why vanishing gradients
are such a big problem
so imagine you have a number right and
you keep multiplying that number by
something in between zero and one that
number is going to keep shrinking and
shrinking and eventually it's going to
vanish when this happens two gradients
this means it's going to be harder and
harder to propagate errors further back
into the past because the gradients are
going to become smaller and smaller and
this means that during training will end
up biasing our network to capture short
term dependencies which may not always
be a problem sometimes we only need to
consider very recent information to
perform our tasks of interest so to make
this concrete right let's go back to our
example from the beginning of the
lecture a language model we're trying to
predict the next word in a phrase so in
this case if we're trying to predict the
last word in the phrase the clouds are
in the blank it's pretty obvious what
the next word is going to be and there's
not much of a gap between the relevant
information like the word cloud and the
place where the prediction is needed and
so an a standard RNN can use the past
information to make the prediction but
there can be other cases where more
context is necessary like in this
example more recent information suggests
that the next word is most likely the
name of a language but to identify which
language we need information from
further back the context of France and
in many cases the gap between what's
relevant and the point where that
information is needed can become really
really large and as that grid gap grows
standard rnns
become increasingly unable to connect
the information and that's all because
of the vanishing gradient problem so how
can we alleviate this the first trick is
pretty simple we can change the
activation function the network uses and
specifically both the 10h and sigmoid
activation functions have derivatives
less than one pretty much everywhere
right in contrast if we use a rel ooh
activation function the derivative is
one four four whenever X is greater than
zero and so this helps prevent the value
of the derivative from shrinking our
gradients but it's only true for when
for when X is greater than zero another
trick is to be smart in terms of how we
in the initialize parameters in our
network by initialing our weights to the
identity matrix we can help prevent them
from shrinking to zero too rapidly
during back back propagation the final
and most robust solution is to use a
more complex type of recurrent unit that
can more effectively track long term
dependencies by controlling what
information is passed through and what's
used to update the cell state
specifically we'll use what we call
gated cells and there are many types of
these gated cells that exist and today
we'll focus on one type of gated cell
called a long short-term memory network
or LS TMS for short which are really
good at learning long-term dependencies
and overcoming this vanishing gradient
problem and Ellis hams are basically the
gold standard when it comes to building
RN ends in practice and they're very
very widely used by the deep learning
community so to understand what makes LS
am special right let's think back to the
general structure of an RN n all
recurrent neural networks have this form
of a series of repeating modules right
the RN n being unrolled across time and
in a standard RN n the repeating module
contains one computation node in this
case it's a 10 8 10 H layer LS PMS also
have this chain like structure but the
repeating module is slightly more
complex and don't get too frightened
hopefully by you know what these flow
diagrams mean we'll walk through except
bicep but the key idea here is that the
repeating unit in an LS TM contains
these different interacting layers that
control the flow of information
the first key idea behind Alice hands is
they maintain an internal cell state
which will denote C of T in addition to
the standard are n n say H of T and this
cell state runs through throughout the
chain of repeating modules and as you
can see there are only a couple of
simple linear interactions this is a
point wise multiplication and this is
addition that update the value of C of T
and this means that it's really easy for
information to flow along relatively
unchanged the second key idea that L
stems use is that they use these
structures called gates to add or remove
information to the cell state and gates
consists of a sigmoid neural net layer
followed by a point wise multiplication
so let's take a moment to think about
what these gates are doing this sigmoid
function is special because it's forcing
the input to the gate to be between 0
and 1 and intuitively you can think of
this as capturing how much of the input
should be passed through the gate if
it's 0 don't pass any of that
information through the gate if it's 1
pass all the information through the
gate and so this regulates the flow of
information through the LS TM so now
you're probably wondering ok these lines
look really complicated what's how do
these LS Siam's actually work thinking
of the lsdm operations at a high level
it boils down to three key steps the
first step in the LS TM is to decide
what information is going to be thrown
away from the prior cell state forget
irrelevant history right the next step
is to take both the prior information as
well as the current input process this
information in some way and then
selectively update the cell state and
our final step is to return an output
and for this Alice hams are going to use
an output gate to return a transformed
version of the cell state so now that we
have
a sense of these three key lsdm
operations forget update output let's
walk through each step by step to get a
concrete understanding of how these
computations work and even though we're
gonna walk through this I really want
you to keep in mind the high-level
concepts of each operation because
that's what's important in terms of
establishing the intuition behind how
Alice teams work and we'll go again go
back to our language model example that
we've been using throughout this lecture
where we're trying to predict the next
word in a sequence so our first task is
to identify what past information is
relevant and what's irrelevant and we
achieve this using a sigmoid layer
called the forget gate f of T right and
F of T is parametrized by a sets a set
of weights and biases just like any
neural network layer and this layer
looks at the previous previous
information H of T minus one as well as
the input X of T and then outputs a
number between zero and one between
completely forgetting that information
and completely keeping that information
and then passes it along this decision
so in our language model example the
cell state might have included some
information about the gender pronoun of
a subject in a sentence for example so
you can imagine updating the LST M to
forget the gender pronoun of a sentences
past subject once it encounters a new
subject in that set in that sentence our
second step is to decide what new
information is going to be stored in our
updated cell state and to actually
execute that update so there are two
steps to this the first is a sigmoid
layer which you can think of as gating
the input which identifies what values
we should update secondly we have a tan
H layer that generates a new vector of
candidate values that could be added to
the state and in our language model we
may
to add the gender of a new subject in
order to replace the gender of the old
subject now we can actually update our
old cell states EFT minus one into the
new cell states EFT our previous two
steps decided what we should do now it's
about actually executing that so to
perform this update we first multiply
our old cell state C of t minus one by
our forget state or forget gate F of T
this forgets what we decided to forget
right we can then add our our set of new
candidate values scaled by the input
gate to selectively update each state
value and so in our language model
example this means that we're dropping
information about the old subjects
gender and then adding the new
information finally we just need to
decide what we're going to output and
actually output it and what we are going
to output H of T is going to be a
filtered version of our internal state
that we've been maintaining and updating
all along so again we're going to use a
sigmoid layer to gate where we're going
to output and we put our recently
updated cell state C of T through
through a tan H layer and then multiply
this by the output of the sigmoid gate
essentially this amounts to transforming
the updated South State using that tan H
and then dating it and in our language
model for example you may want to output
information that relates to a verb for
example if we've just seen the subject a
new subject in the sentence so this
gives us a sense of the internal
workings of the LS TM but if there's one
thing I that you take away right it's
sort of those three high-level
operations of the LS TM forget old
information update the cell state and
output a filtered version right but to
really appreciate how the LS TM helps
overcome the vanishing gradient problem
let's consider the really
in ship between C of T and C of T minus
one right when we back propagate from C
of T our current cell state right to C
of t minus one what you'll notice is
that we only have to perform elementwise
multiplication and an addition and doing
this back propagation there's no matrix
multiplication that's involved and
that's entirely because we're
maintaining this separate cell state C
of T apart from H of T and that C of T
is only involved in really simple
computations and so when you link up
these repeating LS p.m. units in a chain
what you'll see is that you get this
completely uninterrupted gradient flow
unlike in a standard RNN where you have
to do repeated matrix multiplications
and this is really great for training
purposes and for overcoming the
vanishing gradient problem so to recap
the key ideas behind LS CMS we maintain
a separate cell state from what's
outputted we use gates to control the
flow of information first forgetting
what's irrelevant selectively updating
the cell state based on both the past
history and the current input and then
outputting some filtered version of what
we just computed and this this maintain
this maintenance of this separate cell
state allows for simple back propagation
with uninterrupted gradient flow so now
that we've gone through the fundamental
workings of our n ends back propagation
through time the vanishing and exploding
gradient problems and the STM
architecture I'd like to close by
considering three really concrete
examples of how to use our nuns
let's first imagine we're trying to
learn a RN n to predict the next musical
note and to use this model to generate
brand new musical sequences so you can
imagine inputting a sequence of notes
right
producing an output at each time step
where our output at each time step is
what we think is the next note in the
sequence right and if you train this
model like this you can actually use it
to generate brand new music that's never
been heard before and so for example
[Music]
right you get the idea this sounds like
classical music right but in reality
this was music that was generated by a
recurrent neural network that trained on
piano pieces from Chopin and after the
training process was asked okay now
generate some some new music based on
what it is you've learned and you can
see right this sounds like extremely
realistic you may not have been able to
tell that this was music generated by a
machine unless maybe you're you're an
expert piano aficionado and you'll
actually get some practice with building
a model to do exactly this in today's
lab where you'll be training an RNN to
generate brand new Irish folk music that
has never been heard before
as another cool example where we're
going from an input sequence to just a
single output we can train an RNN to
take as input words in a sentence and
actually output the sentiment or the
feeling of that particular sentence
either positive or negative so for
example if we if we were to train a
model like this on a set of tweets we
could train our RNN to predict that this
wonderful first tweet about our class
success 191 has a really positive
sentiment which hopefully you agree with
but that this other tweet about the
weather is actually negative the final
example I'll briefly talk about is one
of the most powerful and widely used
applications of Arlen's in industry and
it's the backbone of Google's Translate
algorithm and that's machine translation
where you input a sentence in one
language and train an RNN to output a
sentence in a new language and this is
done by having an encoder that encodes
encodes their original sentence into a
state vector and a decoder which decodes
that state vector into a new language
but there's a big problem in in the
approach as depicted here and that's the
fact that this entire original sentence
needs to be encoded in a single vector
that's passed from the encoder to the
decoder and this is a huge bottleneck
when you're considering large bodies of
text that you're trying to translate and
actually you know researchers devised a
clever way to get around this problem
which is this idea of attention and the
basic idea here is that instead of the
decoder only having access to the final
encoded state and now has access to each
of these states after each of the steps
in the original sentence and the actual
weighting of these vectors from encoder
to decoder is learned by the network
during training and this this technique
is called attention because when the
network learns this waiting its placing
its attention on different parts of the
input sequence and in this sense you can
think of it as actually capturing a sort
of memory of the original sentence so
hopefully you've gotten a sense of how
our ends work and why they're so
powerful for sequential processing we've
discussed why they're so well-suited for
sequential modeling tasks seen how to
define their operation using this
recurrence relation how to train them
using back propagation through time and
also looked at how gated cells can let
us model long-term dependencies and
finally we discussed three concrete
applications of RN ends and so this
concludes right the lecture portion of
our first day of six s-191
and we're really excited now to
transition to the lab portion which as I
mentioned is going to mostly focus on
training and RNN to generate brand new
music and so the the lab is going to be
broken down into two parts
but sorry but before I go into the
specifics of getting started with the
labs
I'd like to take a few minutes pause for
those of you who you know plan to stick
around for the labs we're happy to have
you
we're also happy to address any
questions that you may have about either
lecture one or lecture two here at the
front and we'll just take a 5-minute
break or so to orient ourselves and get
set up for the lab thank you
[Applause]